At this point you should know what
monetization method you want to use, and
how you'll implement it.
You might also have a plan
B in the back of your head,
in case that first one doesn't work out.
And you should also have a plan for
tracking and
measuring the success of your model.
>> Keep in mind, you can apply the user
segment to creating the previous unit
to any of these reports.
This will help you get insights per
group, which is much more accurate.
As Yogi Berra said,
you can observe a lot just by watching.
In our world, keep watching your users.
>> In the next lesson,
you'll learn how to iterate on your
monetization model, changing your
approach when you're not making
the amount of money that you need to.